I gave birth a little under a week ago
and my parents flew all the way out from Germany to help us,
and it truly takes a village,
especially if you have two toddlers that need to be entertained
as well.
Baby usually sleeps three hour stretches, so that's been really nice.
Lucky insists I wake him up every time she needs a diaper change
or needs to be reswaddled.
So I do that
and then our kids storm into the room and need to hold her
while they go downstairs
and have some breakfast with their grandparents.
I nurse her for the second time
and then make my way downstairs to make myself a hot cup of tea.
Postpartum experience has been so different than my other two.
My body is recovering a lot quicker,
but my emotions are all over the place,
so I'm just trying to give myself some Grace.
Slow down. Also haven't been in the kitchen in almost a week,
so I was very excited to make myself some breakfast this morning.
Wanted to keep it really simple,
so I made an avocado toast and a tomato toast,
sprinkled that with some flaky salt and olive oil.
Obviously had to also top it with some pickled onions.
There's something about simple breakfast that I like.
Lucky also made himself some steak and eggs with some PICO,
and then he went upstairs to make our bed while I got ready.
Step I never skip.
I get Ready every single morning,
even if it's just putting on some moisturizer to get back into bed.
Today was one of those days
where I felt good enough to put on some makeup.
So I did that
before going downstairs and helping lucky do the kids'hair.
He's usually the one doing it,
but today he wanted to give them a trim
and wanted to make sure that I was okay with it.
That's what he did.
And it ended up turning out so well.
Let me tell you,
getting three kids out the house is an Olympic sport.
So it took us a while to get out the house.
But when we did,
we went on a little walk with my parents.
Not too long, because at this point, I was getting so tired.
We stopped by in and out for an early lunch
and had to get some milkshakes.
Combination of chocolate and vanilla is so good.
And then I got back into bed.